STEPHEN BLUM: Thank
you so much, Melanie.
Well, I'm very glad to be here.
Thanks for having me.
I'm going to start
very briefly by talking
about why did I write this book.
And to do so, it's important
to go back and talk
just a little bit
about my background.
So after undergraduate
college, I went to law school,
like a lot of other people did.
And having gone to law
school, I became a lawyer.
That wasn't a good fit for me.
I didn't like being a lawyer.
And in retrospect, part of the
reason it wasn't a good fit
is I wanted something
more related
to taking care of people.
I'm one of those guys who really
likes to take care of others.
As I explored what
else I might do
and had conversations with
people, I was heard to say,
I want to have a flock.
I want to be a
counselor, but I also, I
want flock, like a minister
or a rabbi or a priest.
And then there's a joke in there
about realizing that priests
take a vow of celibacy and
decided to knock priest out
of the list.
But like a minister,
like a rabbi.
And that led to-- I like
to say sarcastically,
a little bit-- that I
invented wealth management.
I didn't really.
Wealth management is really
the financial services industry
realizing that, why
just sell investments
when you can sell investments
and tax-related things
and estate
planning-related things
and you can put
them all together
and have a broader
something to offer.
But in my case, eventually
one of my more strong-willed
friends grabbed me by the
lapel and said, listen you,
you know money and investing
and tax and estate planning
and you can't figure out how
to help people and get a flock?
That's what everybody needs.
That's what everybody
wants help with.
Get out there and just do it.
So I put out a shingle
as a lawyer, that's
what I was trained as, and have
been doing that ever since.
At the same time, I've been
teaching at the Wharton School
the University of
Pennsylvania for 21 years.
I teach in the Department of
Legal Studies and Business
Ethics.
And what I teach most is
negotiation and conflict
resolution.
This book is the coming-together
of those two careers,
and it germinated
out of my realization
that my understanding of how
there could be better ways
to guide people in
their financial lives
grew directly out of viewing
financial life through the lens
of, what would a
good negotiator do.
A good negotiator, as I
was taught as a student
and as I teach them.
And by the way, I should
mention that before getting
to teach at Wharton, I was
a student at the Program
on Negotiation at
Harvard, and so I believe
I had the best teachers
in my field in the world.
And by the way, that makes it
extremely hard-- excuse me,
extremely easy-- to be
a really good teacher
and extremely easy to win
awards, teaching awards.
Just channel what your teachers
did, if you had great teachers,
and do what they did.
The primary themes
of this book-- and I
guess I should
hold it up and say,
this book-- the primary
themes are these.
First of all, anyone can
become a better negotiator,
and doing so will
improve life outcomes.
Investing and other aspects
of your financial life
are simply another
set of negotiations.
Applying the
negotiation methods that
are talked about in
this book-- the ones
that I teach at Wharton,
the ones that are taught
at Harvard, they're taught at
a lot of other universities
around the country and
now around the world--
but applying those to the issues
and the problems of investing
will get you significantly
better results
in your investing, in your
financial decision-making.
Onward with the themes.
Certain systematic
problems arise
as you negotiate in
a financial context,
as you deal with the
financial services industry.
And particular
actions are called
for if you're going to
be successful in dealing
with those systematic problems.
And we'll talk more about them.
And finally, that the fruits of
improved negotiation techniques
in the areas of
investing and dealing
with your financial
life are worth more
than most people
would ever imagine.
I challenge you-- I
think they're probably
worth more than
you would imagine.
And in the final
chapter of this book,
I have a couple little charts
to try to demonstrate that
and, time allowing, we'll talk
just a little bit about that so
that I can try to make
that point to you,
that it's well worth paying
this attention to these subjects
because, hey, it's worth money.
It's worth money to
you as an individual
who is investing and dealing
with your financial life.
Now, a one-hour talk requires
us to make some choices, yes?
We can't really cover
everything in a one-hour talk,
and indeed I hope
students really
get the gist of
negotiating after 42 hours.
One hour, a little
more limiting.
So in light of those
time constraints,
here's what I propose.
I'm going to offer you a quick
overview of the negotiation
methods as they're
presented in the book,
as they're taught at Wharton and
at Harvard and at other places.
In light of the
limited time, I'm
going to only touch on and
just review very briefly
the economic truths
at the end of the book
that I think are fundamental
knowledge if you're
going to be any good as a
negotiator of your investments.
There's some economics
you've got to know.
It's not too hard,
we'll touch on it.
I'll mention topic
areas, and then I'll
encourage you to go off
and do some more learning.
I want to reserve as
much time as I can
for what I refer to as the
systematic problems that
arise in negotiating
your investments.
These are the topics of
conflicts of interest,
asymmetric information,
and a new understanding
of professionalism
that I believe
holds the key to
addressing these problems.
So that's what I hope
to talk about the most.
So with your permission, let's
begin in those directions.
So let's start by talking
about negotiation.
It's what the first part
of this book is about.
And I want to
start by stressing,
look, I wrote this book,
I've been interviewed.
Been interviewed a lot of times.
And a lot of interviewers
say, oh, OK, negotiating.
We know how to do that, so
tell us in three sentences
how do you negotiate
your investments?
And what they're talking about
is people's common sense idea
of negotiating.
And that's not what we're
talking about in this book.
We're talking about
a systemic method.
A way of structuring
negotiation, thinking about it,
breaking it down into its
parts, preparing for it,
gathering the information
you need, and doing it.
So that's what I
want to just give you
an overview of now, this
systematic way of thinking
about negotiation.
So let's start
with a definition.
What is negotiation?
An interactive communication
process that potentially takes
place whenever you want
something from somebody else
or they want something from you.
That definition,
as students quickly
realize when they see
it, is very broad,
and suggests that a lot of
what we do is negotiation.
My teachers at Harvard
urged that a negotiation
could be broken down into
seven basic elements.
So here they are, quickly.
The first one is alternatives.
In negotiation
speak, alternatives
means everything
else that we could
do in the world besides
this negotiation.
You and I are negotiating.
What if we walk away?
What if we can't make a deal?
What else is there are
out there for me to do?
And of course, what else is
there out there for you to do.
If any of you have read
about or studied negotiation,
you know that the
Harvard people went on
to talk about isolating
your best alternative.
And they called it--
BATNA, the best alternative
to the negotiated agreement.
It turns out, this
is where power
comes from in a negotiation.
Understanding your alternatives
and your best alternative,
making educated guesses
about the other side's best
alternative, and taking
a pulse of who's got
the stronger
alternative, meaning
who can walk away
from this negotiation
and be the less diminished.
If I have a very, very
strong alternative,
I can walk away from
this negotiation
and instead of being here-- what
I hoped to get from our deal--
I'm right here.
I haven't fallen very much.
If, on the other hand, you--
if I can make an intelligent
guess that if we
don't make this deal
you have a great ways to
fall because your best
alternative is weaker,
then guess what?
You need to deal a lot, I
only need the deal a little,
I have the power, OK?
That's very important
to negotiating.
Later we're going
to find out it's
tremendously
important to applying
negotiating to things
like investing.
All right, so
alternatives are first.
Second are interests.
And what I always
tell students is,
what you really, really want.
What lies down below
positions-- you know,
how much will you take?
I'll take $10,000.
That's a position.
Below that are issues.
What are the concerns?
And below that are interests.
What are we really, really
trying to get and do.
And I put it to you
that you and most--
let's say all-- negotiators
you deal with, they
have a lot of
different interests.
And finding them out,
discovering the other side's
interests, being well-conversant
with our own interests,
can lead us to
making better deals.
Which leads us to the third
element of any negotiation.
This is options.
Now when I started
studying this,
I said, wait a minute--
alternatives, options,
they sure sound
like synonyms to me.
In negotiation speak, we
need to lose that idea.
They're totally different.
Options are all the
ways we can structure
this deal we are working on.
And alternatives
are all the things
that are totally
external to this deal.
So, options.
I'll trade you my peanut
butter sandwich for your turkey
sandwich.
Or, I'll cut the
peanut butter in half
and I'll trade you half of
the peanut butter for half
of your turkey if you'll
throw in that Twinkie.
Right?
Two options.
Just in the lunchroom
trade, we could probably
come up with a thousand, right?
Lots and lots of permutations.
Well, of all the
options, of all the ways
to structure a given deal,
some are better than others.
Some get us closer
to maximum value
that we're splitting between us.
And indeed, a lot of you in this
room probably know this phrase,
some are pareto optimal,
and some are not.
Obviously we want to
create as much value
as we can before we
go about dividing it.
A bigger pie is just better
to split than a smaller one.
So creating lots
and lots of options,
figuring out which
are the best ones,
and then finalizing a deal based
on the best possible options,
the richest, the options
that create the most value.
And indeed, the
options that actually
get us to more of our interests.
What do we really, really want.
Fourth element, legitimacy.
I've taken to calling this,
outside measures of fairness.
The teachers at Harvard
refer to objective criteria,
and my Wharton
colleague Richard Shell
has referred to authoritative
standards and norms.
What are we talking about?
Outside measures of fairness.
So what's an outside
measure fairness?
Well if you're going to
buy a share of Google stock
on the market today, what
would you pay for it?
Anyone know?
Probably between
570 and 580 bucks.
Thank you for that.
How do you know that's
the right price?
There's a liquid market, right.
And liquid market is one way
to get objective standards.
But it's by no
means the only way.
By no means.
So here's an example I
often throw my students.
I knew a guy who was
having his own house built,
so he hired a contractor.
And the contractor--
the subcontractor--
came to him one
day and said, hey,
how deep you want the
foundation of your house to be?
And he said, I don't know.
I don't know anything
about foundations,
you're the builder.
He said, well I'll
tell you what.
Here's what we'll do.
Most people in this
neighborhood have
spent about $50,000
on their foundation.
So we'll just dig until we
get to 50 and then we'll stop.
That's how deep it will be.
No good, huh?
Why not?
Can anybody put in my language?
Wrong standard, right?
Wrong standard.
What is the right standard?
Obviously the standard we
want is the building code,
which is actually a codification
of scientific standards.
And we want scientists
and engineers
who think about these
things to tell us
how deep our foundation
should be, not a price market.
So finding the right
standards is very important.
Let me also just say
about legitimacy,
no one wants to feel cheated
or taken advantage of
or treated badly.
You don't, and I put it
to that people you're
negotiating with
don't, and therefore
fairness, legitimacy, in
both process and outcomes--
in how we do the negotiating
and in the deals we make--
is very important.
It's important to us,
it's important to others.
The next element
is communication.
Communicating well
is very important.
And over so many years
of teaching and studying
and researching and
thinking about negotiations,
I've come to the conclusion that
the single place they go wrong
the most is misunderstandings.
Miscommunications.
Not quite getting what the other
folks are trying to put out
or they're not getting what
we're trying to put out.
Making communication stronger
and better will bring fruit.
Try to do it.
Next is relationships.
Relationships.
Important, no?
Relationship in a
negotiation, important?
Well as we study it,
students always say,
well that depends
on if you're ever
going to see the person again.
Are you ever going to
see the person again?
I usually end up by challenging
my students that I'm not sure
that I know of any situation
where I'm absolutely positive I
will never see the person again.
It's a big risk to run.
And let me suggest this.
There's a relationship at
this moment in a negotiation,
we're sitting here
talking and negotiating,
there's a relationship
right now.
There's a negotiating
relationship that's bigger.
It's the size of the
entire negotiation, which
sometimes negotiation lasts
for months or weeks or months
or years or even lifetimes and
we usually pull out one or two
negotiations that
have lasted millennia.
You can probably
think of a couple.
So, relationship right
now, relationship
for the negotiation.
Relationship beyond
the negotiation.
Right?
Do you negotiate
with your parents?
You do.
You have a bigger
relationship than that.
You negotiate with
your neighbors,
with the people
around you in life.
You have a bigger relationship
than just your negotiating
relationship, and you don't
want to lose sight of that.
You don't want to damage it.
In fact, what's best for a
negotiator is, can you come out
of it with the
relationship strengthened.
And let me add this.
Every relationship has a
potential relationship.
What could this relationship
be if we steered it
in the direction to get us even
deeper, richer relationship,
which would get us
more of what we wanted.
So keep that in mind
about relationships.
And the final element of
negotiation is commitment.
I put it to you that, as
you're closing a deal,
you don't want an
agreement or a deal
or a handshake-- you
want a commitment.
Here's some plain English.
You want to make it as likely
as possible that the other guy
will actually do everything
that he or she promised
to do through the very end,
through the last promise that
was made.
Now why didn't I
say, and you will
do what you promised to do?
I figure you can trust yourself.
Can you trust yourself
to do what you promised?
And when you start
worrying about,
how am I going to make a
deal that they are extremely
likely to actually do everything
they promised they would do?
You start worrying about
that at the very beginning
and throughout.
All right.
So that's seven elements
of any negotiation.
I now want to talk about four
phases of any negotiation.
And I guess I should--
time for a commercial?
I walk you through in the
first part of the book,
I work you through these seven
elements and these four phases.
Four phases of any negotiation,
the first one is preparation.
Prepare, prepare, prepare.
This is the single best
advice about a negotiation
you can get.
Prepare fully, you'll do better.
Know your stuff, do your
homework, you'll do better.
The second stage
of any negotiation
is information exchange.
Learn and gather everything
you need to know,
and that includes all
about the other people
in the negotiation,
the other side.
Let's do this, because I guess
we have time-- it's OK for it
to be a little interactive.
Let's say you and I are in
a negotiation right now.
What would you like
to know about me?
Anyone?
Depends on what it's about?
OK.
Would you-- I'd
suggest you'd like
to know about my background,
my ethics, my interests.
You'd like to know all the
information you can figure out
about my alternatives and my
best alternative, my BATNA.
What I'm trying to
do, what I care about.
How about how I am
as a negotiator?
How I've dealt with
other people who
are similarly situated to you.
Time pressure, as in the time
pressure I'm feeling right now.
Yes!
Good, time pressure.
What else?
Anything else?
Here's a thought experiment.
Let's say that as I
was driving here today,
my little mobile phone
rang and it was my wife
and she said our little
seven-year-old daughter Libby,
there's something not
right with her today.
I'm a little concerned
and I've decided
to take her to the
pediatrician this morning.
Would you like to know that?
The answer is yes.
Absolutely.
Why?
It goes to my state of mind.
It suggests I might
be in a hurry.
It offers you-- well,
students have sussed out
that it offers you
the opportunity
to do one of two very
different things.
You can either, with
this information,
take advantage of me
because I may be distracted
or I may feel tremendous
time pressure,
or you could offer me a gift.
Such as hey,
perhaps you'd prefer
to put this off and
not do this now.
Or we don't have to
complete this now.
Or I can get you out
of here early, right?
So you either take
advantage of me
or offer me a kindness or a gift
that hopefully I will either,
I will repay
someday, and it will
change how I'm
disposed toward you.
I put it to you
that, if you'd really
like to know even about
my little girl's health,
that you would like
to know everything.
And I think that's
the right answer.
You would like to
know everything
you possibly can about me.
There is one problem with that.
Actually, I'm skipping ahead.
OK.
If you'd like to know
everything about me,
how are you going to get that?
Well, there's three
levels of ways.
You can do research on me, you
can go to your favorite tool
Google and look,
you can ask people,
you can ask other people
similarly situated
to me as you are,
you can ask my wife.
Please don't ask my wife.
And on the first level of
all, you ask me, right?
You're sitting at
table, at least
metaphorically, with
the biggest expert
on the subject of
me in the world.
And [INAUDIBLE], it's
my favorite subject.
I'm happy to talk about it.
But there is a problem
with asking me questions.
What is that?
Anyone?
Right.
The problem is I may lie.
And my suggestion
to you is you take
all the information
offered, you take everything
I will tell you.
But in your head you're
putting in two different piles.
Here this pile is,
this is what he said
and I know of
absolutely no reason
or incentive why he would lie.
And this pile is,
here's what he said,
but I can identify some
incentives for him to lie,
so be careful with it.
But this pile that he may
be lying, is not worthless.
There's a lot of data in there.
It's just not necessarily all
for the truth as it was spoken.
So you want to know everything.
First phase of negotiating
was preparation
and you did that
before we sat down
at the metaphoric
negotiating table.
But the second phase,
information exchange,
now we're interacting.
Now it's you and me, you
and the other parties
to the negotiation.
Learn, gather, listen,
ask great questions
and gather up all the
information you possibly can.
Be patient.
Wade slowly, because
the third phase,
bargaining-- as soon as somebody
mentions a price or a term,
what happens in a
room of negotiators?
Everybody gets back
and gets cautious
and if it's playing cards
they pull their cards
to their chest, right?
The tone changes.
So the big advice
for a negotiator is
do not move from the second
stage, exchanging information,
to the third stage, bargaining,
any earlier than you have to.
Try to hold off as
long as you can.
It probably won't
be long enough,
our tendency is to
want to jump ahead.
But finally we reach bargaining.
You all know bargaining.
It's probably what
before this afternoon
you would have called
negotiating, right?
The great job of
the negotiator is
you're looking to identify,
what can I offer you
that is cheap and easy for me
to offer you that you will hold
dear, and because
you value it so
much you'll be
willing to offer me
things that are
great value to me.
Perhaps they're less dear
or less valuable to you.
And we make those
value-creating trades.
Finally we get to the fourth
stage, closing and commitment,
where-- I reiterate what I
said about commitment before.
You're looking to
make a deal that
works for everyone at least
well enough that the other side
says, yeah, I'm going
to keep my promises
because it's in my
interest to do so.
So those are seven
elements of any negotiation
as laid out by my
Wharton colleague Richard
Shell in his excellent book,
Bargaining for Advantage--
there's another commercial--
and as reviewed and gone over
and perhaps added to a
little bit in my book,
Negotiating Your Investments.
All right.
Now part two of
my book says, OK,
that's what negotiating
is all about,
you can apply this
directly to investing.
First of all, I have to make
the argument that investing
is really just
another negotiation.
And some people haven't
liked that argument so much.
So let me try to make
it to you briefly,
and see if I can win you over.
Let's start with this.
You ever buy a house?
Was it a negotiation?
Were you absolutely sure
it was a negotiation,
or set of negotiations?
Absolutely.
No doubt about it.
You ever buy a new car?
That's the most famous
negotiation in our society,
right?
Going to the car
dealership and going up
against that highly trained
pro at negotiating tricks.
So how come when you go to buy
an interest in an investment,
an interest in a business--
why isn't that a negotiation?
My argument is, it surely is.
What are you going to buy, one
one billionth of this company
Google?
Is that what you buy usually?
One one billionth interest?
It's a negotiation.
And these tools
can and indeed, I
argue, must be used to do well.
Couple other things on this.
The fact that these investments
are traded on exchanges
and priced by liquid markets
does not change their character
as negotiations, but rather
just adds another challenge,
another negotiating challenge.
Oh, OK, this a negotiation
about something
that has this pricing mechanism.
I urge you that you have
to reject the notion
that, because it seems to be--
and I emphasize that it seems
to be-- a take it or
leave it pricing model,
somehow that's
not a negotiation.
And by the middle
of the semester,
any student of
mine who said, hey
it seems to be take it or leave
it so it's not a negotiation,
would get a scolding.
Or a bad mark or however it is
I tell students to turn around,
go the other way.
Just because somebody comes
to you and says, I'm sorry,
this isn't quote unquote
negotiable, does not make it
something other
than a negotiation.
And this is what I said a
minute ago-- buying a house,
buying a car, buying property.
Buying a property interest
that you hope will appreciate,
such as an investment, like a
stock or a bond that you hope
will pay you
dividends, and so on.
Now as quickly as I can-- I told
you, the first part of the book
is negotiating.
The second part of
the book is about
applying negotiating
to investing,
and we're going to
swing around back
to that, to the
systematic problems.
But the third part is
some basic economics
that you need to
know if you're going
to be a good negotiator
over your investments.
So here's some.
Let me start with this.
Economists know a great deal.
They know a tremendous amount.
Now, we make jokes.
We say it's the
dismal science, and we
say economists have predicted
nine of the last three
recessions, and that's fine.
And we take notice that
economists most certainly
do not know what will the
markets do next month,
or next year.
In fact, the most honest
economists will tell you,
I have no idea about that.
But that doesn't mean
they don't know a lot.
They do know a lot.
And yet most Americans
and people in the world
invest as if none of
that knowledge was known.
And I'm going to guess that
some people in this room
sometimes invest in direct
conflict with things
that scientists know.
So the third part of this
book is review, as I said,
and I think you've got to
know this stuff if you're
going to negotiate.
Because, don't forget, what did
I say a good negotiator does?
Does their homework, right?
Knows what they need to know.
Not just about the other side,
you need to know the science.
You need to know the
background of the matter you're
dealing with.
So here's a few of them.
The markets are rational and
price investments correctly
based on what is
currently known.
Therefore, it is essentially
impossible-- more
or less impossible, at
least-- to beat the market.
There are only three ways you
can beat the market, according
to this science.
Through luck, which
is random chance.
Through insider knowledge,
which is cheating--
I should do the other
way-- through cheating,
which is insider
knowledge, right?
Martha Stewart did very
well on that trait,
but she had to go
to jail for it.
And what's my third one?
Oops.
I can't remember the third one.
AUDIENCE: High
frequency trading?
STEPHEN BLUM: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: High
frequency trading?
STEPHEN BLUM: No, high frequency
trading you cannot beat
the market.
You can beat other investors,
right, you can jump ahead,
you can front-run their
trades, basically.
And you've read
Michael Lewis's book?
Good.
OK.
If markets price
things rationally,
which they do, more
or less at least,
and nobody can beat the market,
what is to be done about that?
Well it is irrational
to pay somebody
to do something for you that
scientists know can't be done.
Right?
It's not a smart move.
Yet most Americans
do that every day,
and I put it to
you that all of you
are paying-- directly
or indirectly-- paying
a lot of people a lot of money
to pick individual stocks
for you, individual investments
for you, one way or the other.
And that is something that
scientists basically know
cannot be done.
Except for random chance,
that will not successfully
beat the market consistently
over a long term.
Second economic truth,
past performance
is not going to help you.
Past performance is just a
reflection of random chance,
just like if there were
100 people in this room--
it looks like there
might be, let's
say there are 100 people in
this room-- I want you to all--
you can do this virtually,
don't do it actually--
I want you all to
take out a quarter,
flip it, and try as hard
as you can to get heads.
Good job, 50 of you got heads.
OK, you 50, do it again.
25 of you got heads.
Again.
12 of you got heads.
6 of you got heads.
Again.
You three-- come on.
That's just random chance.
Let's see you three,
let's see one of you
get-- who can get heads again.
One of you gets
heads again, right?
Any skill?
Any anything?
The playing out
of random chance.
That's most of what we
see in past performance.
Another economic truth.
Diversification is the only
free lunch in economics.
It is very valuable to you.
Take advantage of
diversification.
The fourth economic truth
that I want to deal with here
is historical data.
We know what investments and
markets have done in the past.
This is an incredibly
easy thing to study,
because most of the
data is already captured
and in computers.
So dealing with people
who are telling you lies
or making vague statements
about past history
is not a good idea, because
the history is known.
Next important economic
idea-- critical idea-- costs
reduce returns.
I like to say they reduce
them dollar for dollar.
One dollar of cost will reduce
your returns one dollar.
Pulling out unnecessary costs
when investing is of great help
to you in getting better
investment results.
And in light of compounding
over long periods of time,
it is a fortune.
Wall Street churns out a
lot of bad investments,
and they should be avoided.
There's a list in here
of-- a partial list,
maybe not comprehensive-- of
things that I would suggest
are bad investments that
you should steer clear of.
OK, one more thing.
The amount of money at stake--
by doing these things better,
by pulling out the
cost and so on--
is more than you would imagine.
Did I promise you-- oh,
all right, we'll do it
as a game-- there's a
chart in here put together
by one of my students who's
much smarter than I am
and much more able
to do such charts.
But that chart
asks-- shows us this.
I'm going to make
it as a game for us.
If you have a million
dollars and some smart cookie
is able to increase your
returns by 1% per year--
either through pulling out
costs or increasing returns
or some combination, doing
it more intelligently--
a 1% increase per year
on a million dollars,
what has this saved?
What is that worth to
you after one year?
$10,000.
Good.
How about after 30 years?
Anybody want to play?
Well here's the answer.
The answer's a question.
You raise your hand and you
say, hold on there smarty pants
professor, you didn't tell
us the compounding rate,
and we need it.
Right?
The chart in the
back of the book
uses a compounding rate of 7%.
If your investment is returning
on average 7% per year
and you are increasing return
or decreasing cost whatever
it is, bettering yourself by 1%,
how much is that over 30 years?
Well we are tempted to multiply
10,000 by 30 and get $300,000.
But there we've completely
ignored the compounding.
Anybody want to
take a gut guess?
You took a gut guess,
one and a half million?
Not too bad.
What?
OK, that's very low.
The answer, as the chart in the
book attests, is $2.1 million.
So a lot of-- that face.
You're kidding.
Gotta do the math.
OK.
A lot of money is at stake.
I guess that's my chance to
say, you should read the book.
You should do what I tell you.
Because it's not
small, it's big.
Having said that, and
not having too much time
left-- didn't I say I was
reserving almost all my time
for what I'm first
getting to now?
Here's what I want
to talk about now.
The systematic challenges
inherent in almost all
investment negotiations.
Conflicts of interest.
Dealing with people
who have interests
that are in conflict
with our own interests.
Asymmetric information.
The simple fact that they know
a lot more about the situation,
the playing field, what we're
talking about, than we do.
And the issue of trust.
The problem of, we
may be in a situation
where we have to put our
trust in other people,
and who should we
put our trust in
and who should we avoid
putting our trust in.
I want to point out very quickly
that conflicts of interest
are not necessarily
just financial.
You understand a
conflict of interest
in a financial conflict
of interest, right?
You go to somebody and you
say, what should I invest in?
Somebody you;'re
paying, no less,
to tell you what you
should invest in.
And they say, you should
invest in this over here,
because when you
do I make money.
Basic financial
conflict of interest.
How about conflicts
of interest over time?
How about-- the one that
comes most to mind is,
I'm serving you but
every minute that I
spend serving you is a
minute I can't be out trying
to get another customer.
That's a direct conflict
of interest over time.
How about conflicts of interest
over things other than money,
like position or
prestige or notoriety?
And the example I decided
to come up with for you
last night is, I'm not
going to use any names
but there are a
bunch of celebrity
lawyers in our society.
And it seems like
whenever somebody
gets in some kind of
problem-- I don't know,
let's just make something
up, let's say [INAUDIBLE].
And I know you guys are all
very confident in our highly
technological
world, but let's say
that I took naked
photos of myself.
And suddenly, they're all over
the place, and easily searched.
Here come a certain group
of lawyers-- not to me,
I don't matter, but to Jennifer
Lawrence and all the others.
Celebrity lawyers, right?
What's in it for the
celebrity lawyer?
They get paid, probably a
handsome fee, and so on.
But what about the fact that
a young and budding celebrity
lawyer, their career will
be made if it goes to trial.
And if it's settled quietly,
which might be by far the best
choice for their
celebrity client,
it doesn't do much for
the lawyer, does it?
Conflict of interest.
OK.
Let's go to the
second one quickly.
Asymmetric information.
As I said, they
know more than you.
They know more than
you about the facts,
they have more experience than
you, they know the scuttlebutt,
they know the playing field,
they know the published rules
and they know the insider rules.
It's very, very hard to get a
fair shake in that situation,
unless they care to
give you a fair shake.
What are some classic examples
of asymmetric information
working against us in investing?
Well, front running,
which you alluded to.
The idea that if
I know what you're
going to do-- if you're
going to buy something,
it's going to raise the
price at least a little.
And in some situations, a lot.
If I know you're about to raise
the price, I can buy it first.
And then when you
raise the price,
I have an instant profit.
And there's Michael Lewis's
book in a real nutshell.
If I can build these very high
speed information systems,
I can know what you're
going to do before you
do it and I can
jump ahead of you.
So that's an example of
asymmetric information.
How about this one, though.
What about when somebody
guides you to an investment,
and when you go to actually make
the investment they hand you
a contract is 90 pages long.
And you don't have--
anybody here ever signed
such a contract?
If anybody's ever invested in
a so-called annuity product,
you probably have.
That's a contract that your
own lawyer wouldn't understand.
Only a lawyer in that industry
would even understand it,
because it's full of jargon.
It's totally
one-sided because it's
written by the
person, the company,
selling you the
instrument, right?
They know what's
in that contract,
they know what the
deal is, and you don't.
It's a serious asymmetric
information problem.
And finally, trust.
We are put into situations
where we must trust somebody
even though we have not yet
built up a body of evidence
to say, this is
somebody I should trust.
When we are lucky enough that
we are in a situation where
we actually can
make a choice, how
do we go about
making that choice?
These three systematic
problems are huge,
but here's the good news.
Society has struggled
with them for a long time.
They're not-- they may be
huge, but they're not new.
And I'm here today to argue--
and chapter 17 in my book
tries to argue as well-- that
the answer that society has
come up with, in
part, is what we
call the traditional
professions.
Medicine, law and clergy.
When you go to the doctor,
or surgeon, perhaps,
you're in this situation, right?
The surgeon could have
conflicts of interest easily.
If the surgeon
were more concerned
with how do I make the
most money instead of how
do I do best by you, it's
pretty easy, isn't it?
Lawyers-- I'm a lawyer.
Conflicts of interest daily.
Sometimes dozens of them daily.
And clergy.
Your relationship
with the almighty.
These are the
traditional professions,
and they have been
aware of this problem.
Here's what I think the
traditional professions have
come up with.
Long and serious training.
Standards, rules
and regulations.
Codes of professional conduct
that address these problems.
Specifically the codes.
Among the many
things they say are,
when you hit a conflict of
interest, here's what you do.
And you do for your client,
your patient, your parishioner.
Carrot and stick.
Serious penalties for
violation of the codes.
Things like, you
lose your license.
And perhaps most significantly,
in my opinion, very strong
socialization in these values.
To do any of these things and
become a doctor or a lawyer
or a clergyman-- as
I'm talking about it,
as a professional clergyman,
not a mail order ministry--
over and over and over.
The training includes getting
you to think like, and take
in the values of,
this profession.
And those values include
patients come first,
clients come first, and
parishioners come first.
The traditional
professions all understand
in their codes,
their ethics, and
their informal self-identities,
that care-taking
and safeguarding of others is
an integral and essential part
of professional work.
Now I'm not so naive as to say
well, all doctors, lawyers,
and clergy always put
their clients first,
that we don't have any
problems with that.
No, no, we have plenty
of problems with it.
But my argument is that
the professions themselves
take this on, and
that when a doctor
or lawyer or a clergy person
screws up in this area,
they're screwing up in part
against their profession.
They are outside the
bounds of their profession.
They are violating their
professional duties.
As opposed to arm's
length transactions sales
cultures where the codes
don't exist, or the ethos
doesn't exist.
I better hurry up.
So here's my proposal.
A new professionalism,
a proposed definition
of professionalism.
I propose that what
professionalism should mean
is that a true professional is
one who uses his or her ability
and power-- the
knowledge, the learning,
everything you've
gathered-- solely
to advance the best
interests of the client.
And, very importantly,
if you're going
to be a true professional, when
your interests and the client's
interest diverge, you
follow the client's interest
and only the client's interest.
Client simply comes first.
This is my idea and
my understanding
of a true professional.
And my argument is we're making
a tremendous mistake when
we say, well, professionalism
refers to technical knowledge
or experience or
having done it a lot.
I think professionalism
in particular
is about this question of
care-taking and safeguarding
of clients, and following
only their interests.
And that's what we look
for in a professional,
and therefore this
idea of professionalism
must be expanded beyond the
traditional professions.
Advancing true professionalism
in the managing
of other people's money.
We need to apply a
duty of care-taking
in addition to advanced
levels of skill.
This is particularly
critical in our society
because we're becoming
more and more of a you're
on your own society.
You're on your own with
your retirement savings.
You want to send your kids to
college, you're on your own.
We'll help you, we'll help
you with tax deductions,
we'll help you-- your employer
helps you with a program.
But you have to do
the decision-making.
So to abandon everyone
to you're on your own
and you're going to work
with people who are not
professionals, we're not
meeting these definitions,
but rather there,
in a sales culture,
is a tremendous
societal problem.
And finally though-- my
please I guess is this.
At this point I'm going to argue
that the financial services
industry is not a profession.
Rather, it is an arm's
length sales-based industry.
The great challenge for
society and for the industry
itself is to transform
itself into a profession.
In light of the
conflicts of interest
and asymmetries of
information that
are inherent in investing
and money management,
I would say this is
a matter of urgency
for our society as a whole.
However, that's
very nice, right?
And I'm not the first person
who came to this podium
and said we need great
societal transformation
and it'll probably take a
long time and let's all do it,
right?
But one more thing for
you is, let's get real,
this ain't gonna
happen tomorrow.
So what do you do about
your individual situation?
And here is my answer.
The industry-wide changes
we've discussed here
will not take place overnight.
Indeed, even the
first baby steps--
the imposition of
a fiduciary duty
on all financial advisors--
is being fought vigorously
in Washington, DC right now.
To your surprise, most
financial advisers
do not owe you a fiduciary
duty at the present time
at law, which is crazy.
It's what I just
described as a baby step.
And in light of that, it
falls to the individual
to take action for herself.
So here's the prescription.
Here's what I think
you need to do.
I think you need to look for
individuals and companies
to work with who exhibit
these professional qualities
that I've talked about,
and who understand
their responsibilities in
safeguarding and care-taking
of their clients in their work.
In this quest, here's
what you need to do.
You need to do a
lot of preparation.
You need to ask a tremendous
amount of questions.
You need to do your homework
and know the subject area.
Do your research.
Be skeptical.
Own your own power.
This is very important
because a lot of us
mistake financial people for the
people who tell us what to do
and we just accept, like
doctors and lawyers and clergy.
That's a mistake.
You are the one in
the power position.
In fact, to go back
to a concept mentioned
earlier, what's your
best alternative?
Well, last time
I looked, there's
somebody else plying this
trade across the street.
Financial services is the
most competitive industry
in our society.
You've got a lot of choices.
That means you have the power.
Own that power.
Know well your best alternative.
Do not settle, keep shopping
for the professional you seek.
Get everything in writing,
and maintain lots of controls.
Maintain lots of control.
Do not hand excessive
authority over to others.
Practice your
negotiating skills,
get better as a negotiator,
and then understand
that you're dealing with a
negotiation with your finances.
And of course, read
my book, all right?
It is my fondest hope that
this has been helpful to you
in navigating your
financial life,
and that it will result in a
richer future for all of you.
So with that, I
thank you very much.
I think I went over, yes?
Is that what that was about?
I went over.
OK.
But if-- those of
you can stay, anybody
who needs to leave, go ahead,
and those of you who can stay,
I'll be glad to
answer questions.
And I think I'm supposed to
encourage you to buy the book.
And if you do buy the book, of
course I'll be glad to sign it.
I'm not in a hurry.
I'll stay as long as you want.
And if people want to talk as
individuals after questions,
that's fine.
So what can I tell you?
What can we chew around?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So there are a lot
of financial negotiations
I can do like [INAUDIBLE], my
career, my salary-- job things,
right-- If I could invest
my energy in only one
negotiation, what would that be?
STEPHEN BLUM: I'm
sorry, if you--
AUDIENCE: If I invest my energy
in only one negotiation, what
would your top most thing be?
STEPHEN BLUM: Well it's
an interesting question
because I don't want to
be boxed in to just one.
But I think the
point that I'm trying
to make is, don't give short
shrift to the negotiation
about your investment,
your savings and so on.
Don't say, well that'll
take care of itself.
It really won't.
It's really worth the effort.
It may not be more important
than, say, your job
or your future or
figuring out how
you're going to deal with
your kids and their futures,
but it's terribly important.
That's my message.
OK?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So if you
can't beat the market
and want to minimize
costs, is the answer
to just buy SMP500 index
funds and call it [INAUDIBLE]?
STEPHEN BLUM: A great
question because you
have to read my book.
The answer is not to buy
SMP500 funds and here's why.
The SMP500 is an index.
It is not the index,
and in fact it's
not the best index for you.
It's not broad enough.
It's only 500
stocks, more or less.
Well no, not the
best, the biggest.
And there's lots of research
that will tell you--
and you can read about
it not just in my book,
there's lots of places to
read about this-- that you
want to go broader.
Remember about diversification.
And so you want to build
a group of index funds
or other passive
investments such
that essentially
you own everything.
OK?
So you're on the right
track, but the answer
is not the SMP500.
OK, good.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I'm looking-- I'm
apartment shopping right now,
[INAUDIBLE] potentially
purchasing an apartment,
and it's really-- I feel
like I don't trust anyone.
Which seems to be
the correct thing.
I don't trust my
real estate broker,
mortgage broker.
What should I do
to get past that,
where I can make this decision
and feel good about it?
STEPHEN BLUM: The
truth about negotiation
that I didn't
mention is, we always
have to make a
cost-benefit analysis.
The book in my
classes teach you how
to do a big,
important negotiation.
And they say, invest a lot of
the resource of yourself in it.
And so the answer I have
to give you involves
investing a lot of
yourself and a lot of time.
You might not choose to do it.
But the answer that I've
been trying to present today
is this.
It's worth the effort to make
a huge research project out
of finding particularly the
realtor, the one in a million
realtors in New York, who really
behaves like a professional.
Who really-- and you
have to find this
through reputation and
through people who know them,
or perhaps through
personal contact,
but someone who will really do
as I said of a professional.
Who will say, you are my client.
You come first.
And I don't have to make maximum
money off you, because if you
go away saying, this is the
best realtor in New York
and tell everyone who you know,
I'll do just fine in my career.
OK?
So the answer is, negotiate it.
Like a real negotiator.
And negotiate it means do your
research, do your finding out.
Suss out the people.
Learn, learn, learn.
AUDIENCE: Who has the BATNA
in that situation, though?
Because there's
a million buyers,
but there's a
million brokers, too.
STEPHEN BLUM: Well the
answer to BATNA analysis--
and I really didn't
have time to do BATNA,
BATNA takes me a
whole 3-hour lecture--
but the answer to BATNA analysis
is, you always have a BATNA
and they always have a BATNA.
You always have an
answer to this question.
After I've done all my
research and really examined
my alternatives and
really thought hard
about which is the best one,
I always have an answer.
What will I do
after the research?
What will I actually do?
So what will you actually do?
AUDIENCE: Just find someone
else or not [INAUDIBLE].
STEPHEN BLUM: Right.
And if you're
buying an apartment,
obviously-- one of
the things I didn't
talk about but I want you to
read the book and see about
is strengthening your BATNA.
You can always
strengthen your BATNA.
The simple solution on
strengthening your BATNA
is, know three places
you want to buy.
And then knowing that, if I
can't reach a deal on this one
because they're being jerks and
they're being New York realty
people, I can buy this one.
And I only fall this far.
OK?
Good.
Sure.
AUDIENCE: What's your
opinion of Robo-Advisors?
STEPHEN BLUM: Well as you can
probably guess from my lecture,
I think working
with somebody who
behaves like this true
professional I'm talking about
is incredibly valuable to you.
So let me say this.
I think Robo-Advisors,
let me back up a minute.
The word financial
advisor, what does it mean?
Well I give a whole lecture,
another lecture about it
doesn't really mean much.
But there's a lot of
confusion in American life
and financial life because
an awful lot of people
call themselves financial
advisors when what they are
is investment advisers.
That's even how they're
regulated, just by investments.
Robo may be able to do a
reasonably good job of choosing
an investment portfolio for you.
There's a whole lot more
to your financial life,
and I don't know that Robo
can do anything with it.
So the answer is, perhaps
just for investments,
maybe it's-- I don't have a
full opinion, it's just coming.
For a full guidance with
your financial life,
it's going to fall far short.
AUDIENCE: Have you heard
of Personal Capital?
STEPHEN BLUM: No,
I haven't tried
to keep track of all of them.
They're springing up like weeds.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
What's interesting about new
ones like Personal Capital,
it's a Robo-Advisor plus you
get assigned to a live person
to kind of manage your books.
STEPHEN BLUM: OK.
If it was my 2.1
million dollars,
and that's just what you will
say, that's not-- believe it
or not-- everybody in the room
looks pretty young with one
or two exceptions-- we're
talking about 10s and 10s
of millions of
dollars when you're
old because of
inflation and so on.
We're talking about
a lot of money.
I wouldn't work with somebody
who some robot assigned me.
Part of the message of the book
is you want to do your homework
and find somebody who's
really superb and professional
for you.
And it's worth it.
AUDIENCE: What about
if you're worried
about the ethics
of your investment?
I mean, buying a big,
broad [INAUDIBLE] is fine.
Probably be investing
in child prostitution--
STEPHEN BLUM: So you're talking
about what the industry calls
socially responsible
investing, right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
STEPHEN BLUM: OK.
There are a lot of
choices out there.
Some of them are good
and some of them are not,
so you're going to run
into the same problems.
But it exists, and
it's there for you.
But unfortunately of
course it's not perfect.
The way it works, or the
way it tends to work,
is investment choosers
work with screens.
So lists are made of what
they will not invest in,
and they invest in the rest.
Some are better than others.
My advice would be, in
light of efficient markets,
you probably just want
to build your screen
and invest in everything else.
And there are companies
that will do that for you.
OK?
Other questions?
Thoughts?
Criticisms?
No?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
saying that irrespective of
whether you invest in real
estate or stocks or anywhere,
just put it somewhere.
Because eventually over
the next 20, 30 years,
[INAUDIBLE] at the same
rate as [INAUDIBLE].
STEPHEN BLUM: That
question goes to my point
about the history is known.
And you can research it.
What you'll find is,
real estate does not
return what common stocks
do over long periods.
Let's take one minute and
talk about what is a stock.
A stock is an ownership
interest in a company.
And what is a company?
A company is the coming together
of people, machines and capital
under our laws for
solely one purpose.
And hopefully it's a little
broader than one purpose,
but our laws say
for one purpose.
To try to make money.
OK?
They do.
Not all of them do.
Some fail.
Some do poorly.
But on average, they make money.
And don't forget
what I'm advocating
involves you're owning
essentially everything.
So your broad portfolio
of everything of stocks
is going to make
money, it's going
to make the return that
companies make on average.
And it turns out
that common stocks--
these diversified
common stocks--
is probably the best
investment you can make.
On average, it will do
better than real estate.
Because what is real estate?
Real estate is sitting
there and it collect rents.
But companies-- if this great
real estate to be had New York,
you know who you're
competing with to buy it?
Some real estate company.
You can own stock,
you can become
an owner of that
real estate company.
OK?
Good?
You're calling time on me.
Well thank you so much
for doing this with me.
I appreciate it very much.
Thank you.